-Every day, Donald Trump
continues to prove
that he's an increasingly
erratic President
who's unfit for his job.
And now he's apparently
working even fewer hours
and neglecting urgent issues.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Since the publication
of "Fire and Fury,"
the explosive book about his
first year in the White House,
President Trump has been
battling the growing impression
that even his closest aides
believe him to be dangerously
unfit for office.
And they obviously
have a very strong case
since Trump knows virtually
nothing about the job.
But you would think that a man
who ran on a platform
of pure patriotism and who spent
months lecturing athletes
about respecting
the national anthem
would, at the very least,
know the words to the anthem.
[ Laughter ]
And yet Trump seemed lost
as he tried to sing along
to the anthem
before last night's National
College Football Championship.
-♪ Oh, say, can you see ♪
♪ By the dawn's early light ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ What so proudly we hailed ♪
♪ As the twilight's
last gleaming ♪
♪ Whose broad stripes
and bright stars ♪
♪ Through the perilous fight ♪
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
Trump sings the national anthem
the way the rest of us
sing "Despacito."
[ Laughter ]
♪ Despacito ♪
♪ Muh, na-na-na-na-na, muh-ito ♪
[ Laughter ]
Seriously,
how can you be President
and not know the words
to the national anthem.
That's like Peyton Manning
not knowing the words
to the Nationwide jingle.
♪ Nationwide
is somethin' somethin' ♪
[ Laughter ]
Now just two weeks
into the new year,
Trump faces a series
of urgent tasks
that deserve every ounce
of his attention,
from keeping the government open
to protecting DACA recipients
to fully funding the Children's
Health Insurance Program
to providing electricity
to millions of Puerto Ricans
who are still without it.
And yet he's apparently
spending even less time working
than he did before.
The website Axios obtained
Trump's private schedule,
not the public ones that
his staff puts out, and found...
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
I'm sorry.
He starts his day at 11:00 a.m.?
[ Laughter ]
Is he the president or
a lunch waiter at Olive Garden?
[ Laughter ]
All I do is make fun of him,
and I still
have to be here at 9:00 a.m.
[ Laughter ]
Just take Trump's
private schedule from this week
as an example
of how little he works.
Oh, my God. Trump might be
our first President
who works so little,
he technically qualifies
for unemployment.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
It's like Trump
isn't even the president.
He's more like Mike Pence's
out-of-work friend
who has to crash with him
for a while
till he gets back on his feet.
He's the Dupree
of the white House.
[ Laughter ]
Deep cut.
That's a deep cut.
Trump, of course, not only
defers all major policymaking
to his staff
and Republicans in Congress,
he's also so fragile and erratic
that he needs those same people
to go on TV
and lavish praise on him,
as Senior Policy Adviser
Stephen Miller did on Sunday
in this now infamous interview
with CNN anchor Jake Tapper.
-The reality is, the President
is a political genius
who won against a field of
17 incredibly talented people,
who took down the Bush dynasty,
who took down
the Clinton dynasty.
All these so-called political
geniuses in Washington,
whether it be
the big lobbying firms or --
-The only person
who has called himself a genius
in the last week
is the President.
-Which happens
to be a true statement.
A self-made billionaire
who revolutionized reality TV.
-And I'm sure he's watching and
he's happy that you said that.
-I would be with the President
on a campaign plane
with a rally in 20 minutes,
and he would be able --
-You've already
made this point, Stephen.
-He would be able
to come up with material
in the blink of an eye.
-You've already said that.
-A self-made billionaire,
revolutionized reality TV,
and tapped
into something magical
that's happening
in the hearts of this country.
-Ugh.
[ Laughter ]
I'd say Stephen Miller has
a boner, but he already is one.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Seriously,
he looks like someone slapped
a couple of
googly eyes on a penis.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, is there anyone
creepier than Stephen Miller?
He wasn't born.
He just appeared after someone
read an Edgar Allen Poe story
into a cracked mirror.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Also, can we go back
to the first part of that clip
for a second?
-The President
is a political genius,
who won against a field of
17 incredibly talented people,
who took down the Bush dynasty,
who took down
the Clinton dynasty.
-There's nothing worse
than someone
who pronounces it "din-iss-tee."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Miller claims --
Miller claims he's in touch
with the working class,
but he pronounces words
like a British dandy.
What's next?
You gonna tell us
Trump checks his "mo-bile"
for this "shed-yule"
so he can have some "privicy"
during his "le-zure" time?
[ Laughter ]
To borrow a phrase
Stephen Miller might use,
Stephen Miller is a wanker.
[ Laughter ]
With googly eyes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Obviously, with googly eyes.
Also, can I just say,
I'm tired of this talking point
Trump and his toadies
keep repeating,
that he beat a field of 17
incredibly talented people?
He did not.
Let's not forget
the field he ran against
included a narcoleptic,
a malfunctioning robot,
a sentient butter sculpture,
and a guy who was almost
suffocated by his own hoodie.
[ Laughter ]
And when Trump sycophants
aren't available to go on TV
and stroke his ego,
Trump does it himself.
Yesterday, he flew to Tennessee
to sign an executive order
and speak
to the American Farm Bureau.
And at one point, he needlessly
lashed out at the media
and told the crowd
to look up his Twitter account.
-I will sign two presidential
orders to provide broader
and faster
and better Internet coverage.
Make sure you look up
@RealDonaldTrump, right?
-I'm sorry, but it just
strikes me as unpresidential
to plug your
social-media accounts.
He sounds like the end
of a YouTube video.
"If you thought
this speech was dope,
please like and subscribe
for more sick content."
[ Cheers and applause ]
One of the details Trump's aides
have repeated about him
to show that he's mentally unfit
for his job is his penchant
for repeating the same handful
of stories over and over,
and yet again yesterday,
he rambled on
about his 2016 election victory
and reminded the crowd
of his position on guns.
-We're restoring the rule of law
and protecting
our cherished 2nd Amendment.
[ Laughter ]
-Why are you
making the hand motion?
They know
what you're talking about.
The way Trump abuses
the 1st Amendment
makes me want to take advantage
of the 21st Amendment.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Trump is like a guy
playing charades
who doesn't realize
he's not allowed to speak.
"Movie, two words --
Star, Wars.
Boom! We did it!
That was so fast!
[ Laughter ]
But it isn't just that Trump
is growing increasingly erratic.
He's also becoming more lawless.
After repeatedly hectoring
his Justice Department
to investigate Hillary Clinton,
it seems the DOJ
is now doing exactly that.
And on top of that, yesterday,
the Trump administration
announced that it was cruelly
ending the humanitarian program
that allowed 200,000 people
from El Salvador to live here
for more than a decade.
He's working fewer hours
and neglecting the basic
responsibilities of his job,
and yet he's still
desperate for praise.
In his speech yesterday,
he railed on about the election
and his
administration's attempts
to roll back regulations
and insisted to the audience
that they were happy he won.
-We're streamlining regulations
that have blocked
cutting-edge biotechnology,
setting free our farmers to
innovate, thrive, and to grow.
Oh, are you happy
you voted for me.
You are so lucky
that I gave you that privilege.
-Ugh.
[ Audience groans ]
He's so --
He's so gross.
I never thought I'd say this,
but bring back Stephen Miller.
[ Laughter ]
This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]